ESPN's undefeated Marc Spears back on
the show how are you mark near enough
for a crazy night brother now I bet I
bet now does that include a porzingis
trade what do you think I'm not counting
it out they seem pretty peeved about his
lack of communication some senator feeds
in and appear to be exploring all
options and I think this is something
that if you don't do it don't do it
tonight because it just seems like
there's a lot of emotion and you make
mistakes when you make deals with
emotion so I hope they don't hope for
this Knicks fans think they don't but I
don't think it's out of the realm of
possibility either is it possible for us
or you to find out what caused Phil to
reportedly fall asleep during a
prospects workout according to Jay
Williams and bottle that and have me
poured into whatever he has drinking
right now so he falls asleep for the
next 12 hours thus keeping porzingis in
a Knick uniform for the time being is
that possible mark no no how old of you
oh like Phil oh I don't know maybe could
have a t little T little green t he
sound structure e's a green teas around
the other day you need to take a nap
from time to time man we gotta give a
pass on it better my dad takes a nap in
the millet afternoon had you lost his
fastball mark
I don't know if you ever had one because
he's not coaching this is a different
you know situation he's in the front
office he's an executive so you know
just just because I'm good at making
soup doesn't mean I'm good at doing
barbecue it's two different things and I
like the people underneath him I think
he has great great people underneath him
but you can't make decisions based on
ego and disappointment and whether or
not they treated you the right way I
mean it's um he's killed mellows trade
value now you saw on this kid out there
where instead of being upset that he
hasn't returned your texts perhaps you
should go find him and talk to him and
figure out what the deal is because he's
he's too talented and they drafted him
you know so I I just don't know
stand all this but seems like there's a
lot of Eagle involved Marc Spears
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
from ESPN what's going on in Cleveland
is Chauncey Billups mulling over an
option right now uh I think so
I think you should take it I know people
like this isn't the greatest job in the
world but there's only one of 30 and we
don't know that LeBron is leaving and
and be honest there hasn't been a lot of
asking Americans who even have get this
opportunity so the numbers are extremely
low in that regard
I hope Chauncey takes it I think you'd
be great on on Chauncey for a long time
very very bright mind I know the Nugget
stuff we're interested in bringing on
the front office a while ago but kind of
low-balled oh but I hope he takes it and
regardless of whether LeBron stays or
not I think he's somebody that's always
up to the challenge so what do you think
happens this evening top five walked me
through it I know what your mock draft
is but walk me through what you think
will happen and where you think a trade
possibility might hit folks done
Phillies number two ball done three is
where it gets interesting
you know the Celtics keep the pick you
know I'm starting to hear that they
might take the kid from Florida State
which is certainly uh
isaacs which is certainly would be
surprising but they're shopping to pick
know keep an eye on the Clippers keep an
eye on the you know some some other
teams trying to persuade to mind maybe
New York with porzingis that's where the
interesting is with the third pick what
it feels like again not to harp on this
but a Phil Jackson trades porzingis to
the celtics of all teams mark that's it
but it sounds like doesn't even make
sense right to play but no no that's
time they made a trade well I mean we
have however we had Pat Williams on last
hour and Pat said when he was with the
GM with the Sixers for twelve years he
never talked to Red Auerbach for 12
years there wasn't even worth the
they were just not going to deal with
each other which and now but no way now
we're seeing at the top of this year's
open you don't think porzingis in the
celtic uniform would love to come back
to the garden I don't get some of that
we have to stop talking about it because
it makes me nauseous just a mere zealot
I mean we don't do even need to talk
about four or five three is it those
juicy so who would get I can't wait who
would be people be trading into it three
for Fox four for Jackson is a deceptive
presuming you know I mean I know they
love Josh Jackson there so I could see
if the Knicks were to trade for that
pick I could see him getting Josh a lot
of people love Josh so it's amazing to
meet it and look I'm a big fan as I
might be bias I saw him playing high
school a lot up in Napa but he he's
pretty spectacular so I'd be surprised
if the subjects didn't take them but
they didn't work them out Danny Ainge
and the coach had a discussion with them
they seen him play I don't know that
they need to work them out but if if the
Celtics do pick I think they're
intrigued by Isaac's and then that's it
also gets interesting it's what the Suns
are for they like Fox but Fox doesn't
want to be around a bunch of point
guards from his alma mater so it'll be a
little touchy there and then if somehow
Jackson lands the five the Kings might
start crying because a lot of people
feel that the best player to draft need
to go into Sacramento so then faults
last one for you mark this fault and the
process is the process over when he's
drafted by the Sixers what do we what
can you tell me well do do we do a
business if this is going to be yet do
we do a fourth is going to be there's
certainly a lot of young talent there
which 10ms have played some early but I
think there's going to be some pressure
on folks man I mean there's a lot of
naysayers because of what did it happen
in college nobody's really seen them
play I think there's going to be some
pressure on him to really really prove
himself as a winner as a competitor and
those are things they're being
questioned right now but talking to the
people from the Sixers they they are
very excited and they love them best you
can tell was Jimmy Butler told by a
Cleveland Cavalier don't come here
what do you think ah perhaps but if you
mean if he says that but that means
LeBrons leaving right so I mean and to
me that's one of the reasons why
Chauncey has to give pause right like I
know it's a rare opportunity as you
point out but do you want to be the guy
that's sitting there where LeBron leaves
on your watch say what to say the top
you can't convince him to stay well he's
got a convention to stay by surrounding
him right with the right hand with the
guy yeah I think that Chompy has to take
it I just lose this is their guarantee
he's gonna get another one I mean this
is it you go turn down a job of a team
that went to the finals I mean even if
they lost the Brawn they still got Kyrie
in love there's still other players it's
not like he's taken over - I don't
notice the Kings it could be a lot worse
I think you should take it all right
mark appreciate the time enjoy the draft
tonight this seems to be the most
intriguing NBA draft I can recall I
don't know if you feel the same rich I'm
excited man I'm about to get on this
subway and head to Brooklyn right now
okay if you see Phil well I know he
rides the bus but if you see Phil uh you
know give him a nudge I don't think he'd
go take the bus today that may not be a
good move you sure about that cuz I mean
he took the bus at the end of last
season it was all over and he's taking
the buyout but but but if he takes the
bus today it's going to be very very
late and it might be some angry pdms
whoa thanks mark appreciate the time a
people awake at night you know that's
that's true don't hoot with the out if
you who at the owls you can't soar with
the Eagles that's what Rod Woodson tilt
used to tell me all the time
exactly take care mark thanks for the
time all right you guys mark spear the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to